logical situations and state leaders are
in the best position to take our general
national recommendations and translate
them
into more precise guidance for their
state and its conditions
as we approach the vaccine rollout we're
also continuing to expand access to
treatments for covid19
as of this week we've distributed more
than 157
000 patient courses of two authorized
antibody products across the united
states
and allocated a total of 205 000 courses
for delivery to states more than 3
000 sites are currently signed up to
offer these
treatments we've also launched a pilot
program that will explore how to reach
vulnerable populations with these
treatments and offer the treatments in
even more convenient
locations as we mentioned
americans need to know that this
treatment is a possible option for
patients who are at high risk for severe
covet 19 but who have not
been hospitalized that includes all
americans over the age of 65
that's the definition we're using in
this case for risk of severe covid19
receiving this treatment if you're in
that category
could help keep you out of the hospital
potentially
helping to save your life so we want to
encourage the news media
and all americans to spread the word
about the availability of covet 19
treatments and we want to encourage
americans to
start playing the role that they'll have
in an eventual vaccine
too vaccines will only bring this
pandemic to an end
if enough americans choose to take these
vaccines
we now have highly promising efficacy
data that i believe
many americans are encouraged by and
excited about
but i want to encourage americans to get
prepared and to get educated now
visit the cdc's website to find out more
about the vaccines we're developing and
the process they've gone through
if you have questions now or have
questions further down the road talk to
your health care provider about
the importance that safe and effective
vaccines have to our own health
and the health of our communities these
vaccine products will be assessed with
the same
rigor that americans can expect when it
comes to any other vaccine or drug that
is reviewed by the fda
as each one of us here has said we're
excited to take this vaccine and we will
encourage our family and friends to do
so
the final analysis has now been
completed with 94.1
efficacy against moderate and severe
disease
importantly there were 30 cases of
severe
disease in the trial all 30 in the
placebo group so a hundred percent
efficacy
there were 7 500 and some
elderly people with age over 65
and efficacy in that population against
moderate disease
was 87.1 percent
and efficacy against severe disease was
also at 100
since there were no cases in the
vaccine group i think those are very
important data to
keep in mind this exceptionally
uh good data and in fact remarkably
similar
to the data that you have already seen
coming from
with with the pfizer um vaccine and
obviously
as the secretary said the fact that
an external regulatory agency of the
highest caliber and standards equivalent
to those of the fda
the uk mhra has approved
the pfizer vaccine of course they have
not been
part and involved in any of the
politicization
that surrounded the development of this
vaccine and i hope
this will be another evidence for
the american population that the data
with these vaccines
are clear are transparent
and demonstrate that they are effective
and
uh safe for use in the general
population
uh because as the secretary said
vaccines are useless if they are not
uh used to vaccinate
people i think also
really great progress with two other
vaccines in the pipeline
the johnson johnson vaccine which
is a recombinant human adenovirus 26
vector has now recruited a little bit
more than
28 000 subjects in the phase 3 trial
now the the breakthrough that we hope
with this vaccine is that it's
a one-shot vaccine with very fast
efficacy achieved
and a hundred percent compliance so to
speak
uh uh since everybody will get one shot
get the full vaccination schedule
it will be very important by the way for
all americans who get
the modern or the pfizer vaccine to have
their first
vaccine dose and then come back either
three or four weeks later to get their
second vaccine those to complete the
immunization schedule
the the next vaccine in in the line
is the astrazeneca chimpanzee and virus
live vector vaccine uh the phase three
trial that's conducted here
in the u.s under the operation warp
speed
oversight so it's different trial than
the uk
brazil trials that have been
communicated about
last week is progressing very well we
have about 15 000 subjects recruited in
the trial
both the jansen trial and or johnson and
johnson
and the astrazeneca trial are likely to
complete
their efficacy requirement which is the
number of cases accruing in the city
somewhere between very late in december
and the middle of january given
unfortunately that the pandemic is
extremely active
and there is a lot of transmission in
the population
in closing on the side of vaccine just
like to remind you that
fortunately the investments we have made
in scaling up
and starting to stockpile manufacturing
of the vaccines
allow us to feel confident that we will
be able to
distribute 20 million enough vaccine to
immunize 20 million people
in the us in december that's 40 million
doses
then 30 million people 60 million doses
in january
and 50 million people or a hundred
million doses
in march so between december mid
december
and and of uh sorry in in february
and end of february we will have
potentially immunized 100 million people
which is really more or less the size of
the significant at-risk population the
elderly
the healthcare workers the first-line
workers
people with comorbidity i'll close there
of course be happy to answer your
questions later on
and pass on to general perna great
thanks dr salawi as always uh
incredibly well informative for us uh
all right so team today i just want to
talk quickly about uh three things uh
allocation update uh our distribution in
support
of the state plans our our ability to
empower them
to execute their plans and then third
just to reinforce
uh the challenge my word
to secretary azar's comments at the end
about
learning about vaccines so you know
first
reference allocations uh we have
provided the 64
jurisdictions which a reminder is 50
states
eight territories and six mega cities
as well as uh five federal agencies with
their allocations
of the vaccines that are going to be
available in the month of december
what we've done is we believe
for planning purposes only we had to
uh pick a date and i've coined the
phrase snap the chalk line
so that we could plan on actual doses
that will be available
so for example a week and a half ago or
on 20 november
through tiberius we provided the 64
jurisdictions and five federal agencies
their allocations for the pfizer vaccine
of a total of 6.4 million doses that
will be available
a week later on 27 november
we provided the 64 allocation
jurisdictions and five federal agencies
uh their allocations for the moderna
vaccine
at 12.5 million doses that will be
available
again we are planning to be
ready when eua is approved
it is not about getting in front of eua
it's just making sure that we have
everything locked
so when eua decision comes distribution
to the american people
becomes immediate within 24 hours that's
our goal
that's what we're striving for uh and
that's what we're working
to uh you can't execute if you don't
have a plan
and that's what our emphasis is as we
work through all that process
we are going to send half the doses
uh based on allocations uh to the
jurisdictions and agencies
uh because it is a two dose regimen as
dr salawi just talked about
so half of the allocation will be sent
out and then
21 days later for pfizer and 28 days
later for moderna
we send out the second half of
allocations two reasons
one to ensure that we don't over
administer
uh and that we have the second dose on
hand
and second reason is to make sure that
we don't overwhelm
limited storage capability and capacity
at the state level we want to augment
their plans
enable their plans not constrain them
uh from the greatest distribution
capability that they have
we utilize a tiberius platform that we
developed right which is a
capability that takes in all the
informative data
from the states hospitals doctors
offices
pharmacies only on the specification
of vaccine as it is delivered
uh and vaccine as it is administered so
that we can maintain
the flow of vaccine to the american
people as i've talked
about our goal is to distribute within
24 hours after eua
and the first pushes then we want to
maintain a
cadence a deliberate planned
coordinated cadence of delivery of
vaccine as it becomes available
the only way you can do that is if you
see yourselves and we have to see
ourselves from point
of administration all the way back to
point of uh fill finish and in doing so
then we can coordinate collaborate plan
together
uh the distribution of vaccines down to
the states
we have requested that the states lock
in their
micro plans for final distribution of
both
vaccines so for example this week
we've asked the states uh in total
jurisdictions
to have their micro plans in
tiberius by the end of the week or
for december this way we can ensure that
we understand
all the places where they want the
vaccine delivered and at what quantities
they want the vaccine delivered
and then we can coordinate with pfizer
to ensure those boxes
are are prepared and ready to be
distributed upon eua
addresses in the system coordination
with mckesson
the the master distributor through fedex
ups
and then down to the administration
sites really a key
effort by everybody uh we've asked for
the states and jurisdictions to have
their micro plans ready
for the modern vaccine by the 11th of
december which allows them to do the
same planning
and in theory what happens is the
vaccine comes in to where they want
it enables their plan for immediate
administration of the vaccine to the
priorities that their governor
establishes at each state here's the key
the states know their people their
population is the best
and as they follow through with eua
eventual eua guidance and the asip
guidance that was uh put out yesterday
then you have leaders taking
responsibility
and directing a pariah priority
of vaccine into administration or shots
and arms
our our responsibility is to enable
their plan to empower their plan
uh and that's why we've asked for the
micro planning and the detailed work
to happen accordingly after the initial
pushes go out
for pfizer and moderna then every week
right based on the availability of
vaccine as dr salawi
uh alluded to 40 million total doses
uh in december and then january february
march
uh we are going to uh push allocations
as vaccine becomes available we are not
waiting for cluster of vaccine to be
available
and then push we want to have this
rheumatic
cadence uh delivery of vaccine so the
states can best manage it to the
priorities uh
as they've developed it we visualize
uh each week additional vaccines getting
out
and eventually we just continue to build
on the amount of people that get uh
vaccinated
uh and hence on our way to ending uh
this uh
pandemic uh jurisdictions uh
and and uh the governors quite frankly
will decide where they want to go at the
end of the day
and we're enabling to that end so i just
would reinforce
in this point here allocations made
jurisdictions planning we're trying to
enable them
to uh work through their priorities
to best take care of the people of their
jurisdictions accordingly
second i'd like to talk to you about um
how we are working to empower the states
uh and make sure that they are uh well
informed of all the processes that we
have available
i just want to commend the cdc for the
remarkable work that they are doing
the these um these great leaders these
very very talented
professionals well-trained experts
in this field of distribution have
really set up an
elaborate coordination and collaboration
effort with the states they run daily
weekly meetings they work through
detailed
execution of plans they make
recommendations
on how to best facilitize and
operationalize the distribution uh and
then they figure out ways to enable
the state and jurisdiction plans really
well done
uh by the cdc and i'm pretty proud to be
a part of the collaboration with them
second we've worked a very elaborate
update
in talking to the governors either
through
hhs or up through vice president
pence's sessions with them but also
through
individual phone calls to the governors
to their health coordinators at the
leader senior leadership level to make
sure we're answering questions in a
timely manner
and getting them solutions to their
problems
again we want to enable and empower the
jurisdictions
to execute their plans
that is our sole goal our responsibility
to do
and we've worked extremely hard uh two
things i've coached people on
over over communication uh is an asset
to our execution uh and then
second you know you gotta do the virtual
uh circulation right we have to see what
the governors
and their staffs are seeing so we can
best enable them
clearly one of the one of their concerns
that they're working through is how to
do
uh nursing homes lawn care long-term
health care facilities
right and the cdc and ows collaborated
really worked a very extensive plan
in collaboration with cvs walgreens
and other private pharmacies to enable
uh state governor plans on getting to
those
facilities how do we get it out to them
how do we make sure that we're there to
administer to them and i am incredibly
confident
uh that these uh private uh public
partnerships are ready to execute based
on
the governor's priorities and plans to
do so
uh and i am excited uh to watch that to
get
operationalized the last thing i'll
leave you with
in touching with um secretary azar's
comments
uh and reinforcing dr salawi's comments
on
uh really the great potential and
efficacy of the vaccine
is as we go forward uh vaccine is only
good
as it being administered to the american
people
uh and so i just ask everybody to
uh to really educate yourself right
figure out you know what you want to do
as an individual
but be informed in your process don't
allow
one headline to determine what you're
going to do
there is so much available information
uh and
i just encourage everybody uh uh as
an individual a community uh and of
course
as a part of our great nation to really
inform yourself
and then make the decision that is best
for you
uh and your family and so with that dr
slaughter i think we'll take questions
i have questions thank you operator we
can open it up for questions now and a
family reminder
to our meeting friends that we're asking
a question please state your name and
publication
and please keep your questions as short
as possible so we can get to as many
questions as we can
in the time that we have i'll turn it
over to you operator
thank you we will now begin the question
and answer session
if you would like to ask a question
please press star one
please don't meet your phone and record
your first and last name as well as your
organization
clearly when prompted to withdraw your
question you may press them too
once again at this time if you would
like to ask a question please press star
one
and our first question is from meg
terrell if you wouldn't mind staying
your organization your line is open
thank you it's meg terrell with cnbc um
dr slali i was wondering if you could
just sort of go back through
those allocation numbers per month that
you laid out at one to make sure we
we got it right you know the 40 million
doses december
60 million january 100 million in
february is that just pfizer and
modernist vaccines
and then to follow up on something uh
general purno was saying
with only half the doses being sent out
and then the second half being followed
up to ensure
proper storage what is the right way for
us to talk about
the number of people who will get their
first shot with these doses you know in
the first 6.4 million
is that 6.4 million people getting their
first shot
we often divide by two and say it's
enough for 3.2 million people so what is
the right terminology for us to be using
thank you meg for the question so the
numbers were indeed and i used the
number of
people to be vaccinated with the
complete
dose of vaccine so two shots 20 million
in december 30 million
in january 50 million in february and
that's
with the pfizer and moderna vaccine
there is a chance
that we may have more vaccine doses
available in february
uh particularly with the johnsons
vaccine
if the johnson vaccine gets emergency
use authorization
approved so as i said it's possible
depending on the number of cases
accruing
that that uh phase three trial completes
its efficacy endpoint during the month
of january so there may be a scenario
where we could have a little bit more
with a one-shot vaccine with that
vaccine one of those equal one person
immunized
my recommendation is to use a number of
people immunized
i think it's it's more factual i mean
more real
to people
our next question is from john collins
with
science magazine your line is open
hi um you you pray
dr slowly and um secretary apes are
praised
the decision by the hra to advise her
but the ema in europe and many european
leaders have
purely criticized it as being hasty and
our own fda process
obviously is transparent and slower
meant to build confidence i wonder
whether you want to clarify
things that others are heavily
criticizing in europe
but we don't know exactly how
the process has taken place uh
as you know we stay totally away
from the regulatory process whether with
the fda or with others
what we understand is that there have
been
rolling submissions where different
parts
of the file to be authorized
have been submitted at different time
points i
i would speculate that pfizer
manufacturing
cmc part of the file must have been
filed quite a while ago
uh and uh and therefore potentially
uh the review has focused on the
on the clinical side the rest of it
having done been done earlier
but frankly i cannot comment what i
would agree with you completely is we
know the fda process
is a completely transparent process with
independent experts commenting and
asking questions and
recommending or or or advising the
agency
and we will imminently be going uh
through it
i know personally from my experience in
my previous lives
life that the mhra is an extremely high
grade
agency in fact within the ema before
they
uh left it they were certainly the
the scientific engine the uk and and the
pi
the german part of the agency thank you
our next question is from zachary
brennan
please state your organization if you
may your line is open
uh thanks for taking my questions back
from politico so
uh general porno mentioned earlier that
about 21 jurisdictions still haven't
signed on to these data user agreements
what's going to happen with those
jurisdictions if they ultimately don't
sign on to those
and then can you talk a little bit about
why certain states are saying that
vaccine allocations are a lot smaller
than what they
originally had thought so
yes so first question um
we're down to 17. we are
really getting to the last dot the i
cross the t
and i feel very confident that uh
confident that all the jurisdictions
will have their data use agreements in
uh and everything will be all right
uh to your second question what we're
doing is
is instead of waiting until the end of
december where we know we'll have a
cumulative
amount of vaccine as doctor slowly
mentioned and i reinforced
that 40 million doses um what we're
doing is
at the time of we speculate eua
is going to occur the doses that'll be
available is 6.4 million for pfizer
and 12.5 for moderna and that's what we
did the initial allocation based on
and so that push will go out based on
those allocations
but every day that goes by after the
initial push
additional vaccines come off the shelf
because they've been certified
and approved for distribution and
administration
hence what i talked about the continuous
cadence
of delivery of vaccine going out to the
american people so it's not a one and
done
it's a initial push and then a
continuous
uh cadenced flow of vaccine
for planning and coordination and
execution
thank you
our next question is from stephanie ebbs
with abc news your line is open
uh thank you so much from abc i wanted
to follow up on that
general purno when you're talking about
the the continued cadence of deliveries
how will the amount in those deliveries
be allocated
um and is it correct to say that then
each subsequent delivery would be
followed by
a delivery of the same amount you know
21 or 23 days later
so what we're doing is through tiberius
the program that we established which is
located at
each of the jurisdictions we're
establishing
the available doses of vaccine to each
state
and so they get to see that the the
tiberius allows them
to see the allocation allows them to go
through a planning process of where they
would like to have the vaccine to go to
manipulate it so that they can see you
know impact
of the doses going to those locations
and then once it finally approved
they hit send and that is how we
distribute
so quick answer to your question is
through tiberius
open and transparent with each
jurisdiction as allocations become
available and then the second part of
your question
i apologize i i don't remember it
does anybody help me on that one i can't
remember because it was the allocation
in the states how we allocated those to
each other yeah so
per paratha
oh i apologize i apologize thank you so
the second part of the question was is
are we going to hold
the second dose for every distribution
as we go
forward in the cadence and the answer is
yes or
our our uh uh responsibility
is to make sure that we have both doses
in hand
before we send the first dose out that
way we're
always confident that the second dose
will be available
for everybody as they get administered
their
shots over thank you
over
our next question is from steve
hausen with biosentry your line is open
i i wanted to ask if there are any
systems in place for tracking
outcomes for people who are vaccinated
are there any registries or or other
systems for
uh determining what the outcomes are on
an ongoing basis
yes so the the fda and the cdc
are working very closely together to put
together
a very active pharmacovigilance and
surveillance system
using various very large databases
currently in use